good
evening thank you all so much for coming
uh we had to turn the chairs around I'm
told because the lighting is better here
for the video so apologies for any
inconvenience but those who came in last
and on the back row you know what they
say the last sh be first first sh be
last in any case uh I thank you all very
much for coming this is an
extraordinarily important issue as we
have just seen yet again in Boston now
now it is there's a great deal of
information that's come out about what
happened in Boston and it is very
important to note some of the details
that should be kept in mind one of them
is that the Russian authorities notified
the FBI about tamaran sarv the older
brother several times telling him he was
meeting with jihadis in dagistan in the
Caucasus and that he was somebody they
should keep an eye
on not only that but it has just come
out also that this outlandish mother
that they have who says Allah abbar and
I don't care if they kill my other son
and they kill this son and I will just
say Allah abbar and she says that they
were framed because of course America
wants to frame Muslims and hates Muslims
and all this nonsense she was on the
terror watch list also and Tamil and sah
was on the terror watch although when
the Russian authorities went to the FBI
the FBI essentially did
nothing now the angle on this story as a
massive failure of American intelligence
and law enforcement I think has not yet
even begun to
unfold and maybe it never will because
there are lot of people in power who
have a lot of reasons to shove it all
under the road nonetheless enough has
come out already so that we can know
that it was a massive failure of law
enforcement and
intelligence now why did it
happen why did the FBI not keep an eye
not only did they not keep an eye on him
they they they were so completely not on
the case that he was able to amass the
ingredients for these bombs that were
made according to the specifications of
the al-Qaeda magazine
Inspire and nobody was paying any P
attention to this guy on the terror
watch list as he gets these bomb
materials
no I think this is the
fruit of something that was set in
motion several years
ago
and
unfortunately part of it has to do with
events in which I was actually directly
involved
in
2010 I spoke to a military group in
Louisville Kentucky and I used to give
training to Military and
FBI and to Joint terrorism task force
and to various other agencies about
Islam and explain to them what it is in
Islamic texts and teachings that makes
people want to kill
people because after all it's the
fundamental rule of warfare know your
enemy and if you don't understand the
motives and goals of the people who are
trying to kill you then you can't stop
them but the more you know them the more
you were able to outthink them and so
the US Military and the FBI used to
bring in me and many other people who
work in the same field and we would do
this
training but then in
2010 I spoke at this in Louisville at
this military
base and
published a photo on my website Jihad
watch of me standing with two of the
hosts who were active US military
personnel at the time now I did this on
purpose because the Council on American
Islamic relations which is a Hamas
linked Muslim Brotherhood front group in
the United States had already started to
put pressure on the military for
bringing in me and others like me to
speak and so
when I got there the people at the base
said you can't tell anybody you were
here and I thought wait a
minute is this the United
States is the US military so afraid of
Hamas and the Muslim Brotherhood that
they're going to let them dictate who
they can bring in and who they
can't and I thought you know I just
can't go along with
that it was the principle of the
thing that if the US
military on the front lines of
protecting this nation I mean that's
their only purpose or what ought to be
their only purpose is cowt to people who
are essentially on the other side then
we're in
trouble right and so a couple these two
officers who were among my hosts they
agreed with me and that's why they
posted for the picture and why we put
the picture
up but they did ask that the in Insignia
their Insignia be obscured and so on and
so I did that however on the back wall
was the logo of the place
itself and we forgot about that and so
the Council on American Islamic
relations complain and they wrote to the
military base in Louisville they wrote
to the uh Secretary of Defense they
wrote To The Head of the FBI they got a
huge Coalition they got Reverend Jesse
Jackson to complain they got all kinds
of people to complain because I was
training military
personnel and they broadened it out and
began a
campaign to get all of the training
materials that were being used by the
FBI and other intelligence agencies and
DHS scrubbed of any mention of Islam and
Jihad and all the trainers like me be
removed
and they did in
2011 fatimaa who is the head of a Muslim
afriy group in the United States along
with 57 other Muslim organizations
including these Hamas linked Muslim
Brotherhood groups like The Council on
American Islamic relations the Muslim
American society the Islamic Society of
North America and others wrote to John
Brennan who was then the deputy National
Security advisor and said uh you you
you've got to cleanse the training
materials of all this islamophobic
material and they specified they said
you got Spencer in there and you've got
Steven codin who is a great man who is
the uh only Authority on Islamic law in
the Pentagon for many years until he was
uh cashiered at the behest of Hisham
Islam the deputy the assistant to the
deputy secretary of
defense and various other people and
various other the materials they listed
it all they said this has all got to go
it's racist what racist Jihad Terror I
always forget and it's bigoted and
islamophobic and hateful and so on okay
Brennan wrote back I think maybe 40 or
50 seconds
later and he said yes we're so sorry yes
we're going to scrub all this we're
going to undertake a massive effort not
only are we going to scrub all this but
we're going to retrain everybody who was
trained by this Char or these
trainers and we're going to make sure
that there's nothing about Islam or
Jihad in any terror training
materials now look how many non-muslim
terrorists can you really
make I I keep hearing about Timothy
McVey and you know eventually there's
got to be an expiration date on that
it's been almost 20 years and Timothy
McVey represented no organized movement
there are Islamic jihadis in every
continent and pretty much every nation
of the world there are armed Islamic
jihads going on against non-muslims in
the Philippines in Thailand in Indonesia
in Malaysia in uh Burma in Iraq in Chia
in Nigeria in Egypt and Syria and all
over the
globe but that's the one Terror threat
that the the the the the deputy head of
National Security and now the CIA
director said we won't talk about
it okay so along comes tamaran
sarv and the Russian authorities say he
met with a Jihad leader in in
dagistan and he met with him six times
and we think this guy is
trouble and he get they get this in the
defanged politically correct sanitized
retrained deprogrammed or reprogrammed
re educated
FBI how did they know what to look for
how did they know what the danger signs
were how did they know what on Earth to
un how on Earth they could understand
what they were even seeing if they
looked into this man's activities they
were forbidden to look into anything
that would have made it make sense to
them they were not allowed to look into
the very things that would have made it
all make sense
and so what
happened now what this is is a concerted
effort and it is part of a much larger
effort and the effort that we see that
we see bearing fruit in Boston that we
saw bearing fruit in Boston and that we
will continue to see bearing fruit the
effort is the an aspect an element of
the same goal that the Boston bombers
themselves had
why did they want to kill people at the
Boston Marathon just to kill people were
they just
Psychopaths obviously not at this point
quite a lot has come out about who they
were and what they were all about they
were Islamic jihadis what is the Islamic
Jihad the Quran mandates that Muslims
must wage war against non-muslims in
order to bring them under the rule of
Islamic law that's what the Mayhem is
for it is to terrify to ter teriz Us in
accord with the Quran 8:60 which says
that Muslims must strike Terror into the
hearts of the enemies of Allah but the
terror is not just undifferentiated fear
it's for a
goal and the goal is that Islamic law
will reign over the whole
world the goal is ultimately to weaken
our society and consider the hundreds of
billions that we have spent since 911
on security on trying to fight this on
uh so many measures to try to prevent
this from happening
again
increasingly wrongheaded and misdirected
but nonetheless they have crippled the
US economy by means of this terror
attack on September 11th 2001 and that's
what they wanted to do that's what they
were trying to do and the ultimate goal
is to destroy the United States
government alog together and replace it
with an Islamic
government the chapter 9: 29 of the
Quran says fight against those who do
not obey Allah and his messenger and do
not forbid what he has forbidden even if
they are of the people of the book
that's us mostly people of the book are
primarily Jews and Christians and that's
mostly what you have in the United
States until they pay the gizia which is
a tax that is levied on the non-muslims
who are subject to the Muslims in the
Islamic State with willing submission
and feel themselves subdued now what
does that mean I happen to have the
Quran with me
tonight
and this is a Quran that I got actually
in the Finsbury Park Mosk the Finsbury
Park Mosque is in London and I was over
there and uh I went on a tour of mosques
and went in and uh they were very
friendly in all of them and this one
they late uh loaded me down with books
the Finsbury Park Mosque was famous a
few years back because it was the Mosque
of Abu Hamza Al masri Captain Hook who
has two hooks for his hands because he
is uh he he's a very Pious man and he
lost his hands in a bomb accident what
the bomb that he was preparing in the
cause of jihad as well as an eye and Abu
Hamza Al masri is now in prison actually
he's been extradited to the United
States for plotting Jihad activities
over here
here and I went into this mosque and I
said didn't you have a little trouble a
few years back and they said oh yes we
did but now it's all gone those people
are gone and we're all
moderates and they gave me this
Quran and this Quran is very helpful
because it's got commentary on it
doesn't just have the quranic text which
can be very confusing and hard to
understand but it's got commentary by
one of the leading Islamic scholars of
the 20th century molana maludy say abua
Mali who was a Pakistani Jihad theorist
the founder of jimat islami which is
still the largest Islamic supremacist
pro- Sharia party in Pakistan and maudi
also wrote a commentary on the Quran he
was very well respected you go into your
local Islamic bookstore you'll find
books by
maludy and so I got this moderate
Quran and it's got a comment on that
verse and it says the purpose the verse
that is that says fight the people of
the book until they paid the gizia with
willing submission and feel themselves
subdued until the non-muslims in other
words submit to the rule of the Muslim
and he says the purpose for which
Muslims are required to fight is not as
one might think to compel the
unbelievers into embracing Islam and you
always hear that it's Islam is not about
forced conversions okay great but what
is it for rather its purpose is to put
an end to the suy the rule of the
unbelievers so that the latter are
unable to rule over people the authority
to rule should only be vested in those
who follow the true Faith unbelievers
who do not follow this true Faith should
live in a state of subordination did you
get
that that the authority to rule should
only be vested in those who follow the
true faith that is Islam in other words
non-muslims as Mai himself put it in
another place non-muslims have
absolutely no right to wield the Reigns
of power in any part of God's Earth and
if they do the Muslims have the
obligation to dislodge them from That
Power by any means possible now the
Boston bombings were for that goal
that's what they were ultimately for
that's why it was done it was part of
the attempt to weaken the United States
so that the United States ultimately
Falls but there is another aspect to
this war it is not just about blowing
things up and killing people the other
aspect to this war is to render us
unable to speak about it and thus
paralyzed in our ability to resist it
and that is for the same
goal of ultimately
destroying the free country in which we
are still living sort of and replacing
it with an Islamic
State the Muslim Brotherhood is of
course as you know in power in Egypt now
but it's not just an Egyptian entity all
of the major Muslim organizations in the
United States are tied to the
Brotherhood their Brotherhood groups and
the Brotherhood according to a captured
internal document that was released a
few years back is dedicated in its own
words in the United States to
eliminating and destroying Western
Civilization from within and sabotaging
its miserable house so that it falls and
a lost religion is Victorious over other
religions now that's why the bombers
bombed but this is also why the Muslim
groups pressured the FBI and the other
agencies to scrub all the training
materials of any mention of
Islam in the first place Islamic law
forbids criticism of
Islam on pain of death and so by
scrubbing the trading materials the
United States government was already
acquiescing to an element of Islamic law
which is the the goal that's the whole
point to get us to accept Islamic law
and so they've already got one foot in
the
door but but also obviously if we can't
talk about this then we can't formulate
ways to counter it effectively and we
saw the bitter fruit of that in Boston
these FBI agents I read that there was a
te a cell a Sleeper Cell that these guys
were connected to I only heard that
reported Once In The Daily Mirror which
is a British
newspaper and the Daily Mirror said that
they had information that there was a
12-man Sleeper Cell that the Saria
brothers were part of and that 1,000 FBI
agents were on the street now looking
for these 12
guys and I thought get 10,000 get
100,000 get all the FBI agents in the
land it doesn't matter because they
don't know what to look for and they
don't know how to understand it when
they find
it and
so the problem that we
face is much larger than most people
have any
idea because not only is this happening
in the government but it's also
happening in the media have you ever
noticed you could have noticed this past
week if you haven't never noticed before
but it is an ongoing pattern that
happens every time there is a Jihad
terror attack or Jihad Terror have you
ever noticed that the newspapers have
been
full this past week with stories about
mosques asking police for extra security
and bracing for a
backlash because we all know that
Americans are so out of control and so
crazy that innocent Muslims constantly
get
victimized well of course none of that
really ever happens there's never been a
backlash of course there are a few
people who say do things to people or
there there have even been some cases of
people being violent toward Muslims when
there was no other reason apparent but
that they were mad about Jihad Terror
however the Council on American Islamic
relations is so desperate to find these
instances of backlash that they have an
annual report about hate crimes against
Muslims and it
includes faked hate crimes
it includes Muslim store owners burning
down their own store and collecting the
insurance money and they never correct
the report when this kind of thing comes
out and there have been many instances
of these fake hate crimes and why is it
because hate crimes for the Muslim
groups in the United States which are
Muslim Brotherhood groups are a big
business why why are there so many
stories about backlash and why is the
Muslim Community want heat crimes
against themselves it's all part of the
same
thing that if
we are not aware of this threat then we
will not fight against it and what they
try to do and have done very
successfully is turn the attention of
the mainstream media away from the
reality of the Jihad threat and onto the
idea of Muslims as
victims and the Muslims as victim
stories always fill the papers after a
Jihad Terror plot or
attack and yet hate crimes against Jews
are actually eight times more common in
the United States than hate crimes
against Muslims but how many times have
you seen in the mainstream media a
consideration of what to do to combat
anti-Semitism in the United States
versus how many times have you seen in
the mainstream media stories about what
we can do about the rising tide of
islamophobia
it's very clear that this is a
coordinated propaganda
campaign and that it is very skillfully
designed in order to make good people
decent American people who love their
country intimidated into thinking that
there's something wrong with resisting
Jihad and talking honestly about the
Jihad threat I just quoted the Quran a
little while ago right and in doing
that I explained that the the Boston
bombers were trying
to do something that is taught in the
Quran the holy book of Islam and is
sanctioned by the Islamic faith we don't
have the time but there is a mountain of
other evidence from the Islamic sources
that established
that but think about what the US
government signed on to and what the
Muslim groups were asking them to sign
sign on to when they got the training
material
scrub they were asking them to accept
the
idea that to look into the motives and
goals of jihad terrorists which is what
all the training materials were about is
racist bigoted and hateful and
islamophobic and when I talk about it
they say the same thing about me when
anybody else talks about it they say the
same thing about them and the news
papers never
discuss these these aspects of Islam or
the motives of the bombers and what
there has been is a ludicrous hunt over
the last week for the motives of the
bombers even after jard jard SV
said we did it to defend
Islam Salon magazine ran a piece why are
terrorists so often
men yeah that's it well
why are saxophonists so often men why
are garbage collectors so often men it's
it's totally irrelevant to the question
they didn't do it because they were
male they did it because they were
Muslims and yet
when this is discussed openly and
honestly it is considered hatte
speech it is considered some kind of an
offense against
decency and something that the American
Muslim advocacy groups with the Willing
help of the mainstream media are doing
their best to rule out of the public
discourse and to render unacceptable to
discuss so I I applaud you for having me
here and of course this is an act
chapter and you're already well aware of
a lot of these things and the dimensions
of the threat but you should understand
that you know it was mentioned uh
earlier that I was cancelled by a uh
Catholic Men's Conference last month in
Wester Massachusetts you have to
understand that these kinds of things
are exactly the same struggle it's just
another front in the same battle what
they're trying to do
systematically is
demonize and marginalize and thereby
render ineffective
anybody anybody and everybody who speaks
out about these things and so
I got the I got the invitation to speak
at this conference and as soon as the
Boston Globe found out about it and as
soon as the Muslim advocacy groups found
out about it they
protested and the bishop of Worcester
immediately caved in non Darwish was
supposed to speak at Columbia University
and at Princeton same thing happened
Muslim groups complained she got
cancelled Pamela Geller was supposed to
speak at a synagogue on Long Island same
thing happened she got
cancelled this happens over and over
again all over the country and the thing
is is that these groups that bring
people like us in they do not realize
what's going on they do not realize what
is happening and they think well you
know we just wanted to have an event
about the threat and this guy is way too
controversial and so we'll just have to
get somebody
else what they're trying to do is render
the truth so controversial that we will
back away from
it and that we will accept the big lie
and it's no less of a big lie than the
one that Joseph gerles put across on the
Germans that will accept the big lie
with
alacrity and not do anything about it
and nobody will be left to speak out
about
it and so you see it's all tied
together that there is an effort on the
one hand to shut up the government and
they got them because Barack Obama was
absolutely willing to do this eager to
do their
bidding and they got the
media to be quiet now the media mostly
As We Have Heard many times survey after
survey shows that most media people are
on the farle
politically and you know the far left
I'm not going to shiot it is
increasingly anti-American
increasingly at odds with any attempt to
defend the United States or to defend
the principles on which this country is
based and so they see this other rapidly
anti-American group the Islamic jihadis
and of course they're also non-white
non-Christian non-western they can do no
wrong and they see everything in racial
terms on the left they're the real
racists who see everything as a racial
issue and they see well the United
States is mostly white and these Muslims
they're most Brown the Muslims must be
right and they have some some legitimate
griev actually this is not a racial
issue at all this is an issue of an
authoritarian and supremacist ideology
that will deny us basic rights and is it
a contradiction to the Constitution and
to the freedoms that we are guaranteed
by the Constitution in numerous
particulars and that brings us of course
to the First
Amendment these are all free speech
issues and the organization of Islamic
cooperation which is 57 Muslim
governments around the world 56 Nations
and the Palestinian Authority is the
largest voting Block in the UN since the
demise of the Soviet
block and they have for years been
pursuing attempts to compel the West to
criminalize criticism of Islam and to
get the United States to actually
Outlaw speaking about Islam in ways that
they do do not like now this might seem
absurd and uh in the early two 2000s the
uh Bush Administration resisted this and
rejected it at the UN every year when
they would try to bring these
resolutions the Obama Administration
signed
on resolution 1618 of the United the
United Nations Human Rights Council
calls on member States to criminalize
what they call incitement to religious
hatred or defamation of religions no
I just quoted the Quran and quoted the
commentary by a leading Muslim scholar
who's internationally renowned and
respected was that incitement to
religious hatred it's in their book if
there's religious hatred they said
it that stuff about the non-muslims have
no right to rule and have to be in
submission to the Muslims I think that's
their hate speech I'm saying you should
resist that in the name of freedom and
equality of Rights for all people before
the
law but you see incitement to religious
hatred that's what they would call that
they would think I just did some of that
by saying that there are Muslims who
believe that and are acting upon it and
are working on it in the United States
right now which is a rather obvious
fact and so the Obama Administration
signed on now a lot of times I I talk
about these things uh I don't know if
you're raising your hand to ask me a
question but I will have questions at
the end so give me a little while and
I'll get to you the Obama
administration had to recognize that the
United States has this pesky thing the
first amendment that guarantees the
freedom of speech the founding fathers
were extraordinarily wise to put that
into the Bill of Rights because freedom
of speech is the fundamental Safeguard
against tyan
there is nothing else between us and a
dictatorial government that can do
whatever it wants if we can speak out
against it though then we can rally
opposition but if we can't speak out
against it then forget it they can they
can they can run rough shot and so the
Obama administration had to recognize
that we have this and that they were
essentially going on record the United
States government was going on record at
the United Nations against the United
States Constitution
and they said that we're going
to we understand that there are
countries that have these freedom of
speech Clauses and so we asked them to
work to find other
strategies in order to safeguard there
the idea that there's no incitement to
religious hatred and Hillary Clinton was
asked about this after she signed on to
this resolution and she said uh yeah I
think that we should uh subject reject
the people who incite to religious
hatred to a good oldfashioned public
shaming and when I read that I thought
what you can do put me in the
stocks what is this uh Plymouth
um the thing is I realize now what she
meant what she meant was the people in
the mainstream media who carry out this
agenda would assist and ab bet the
demonization of anybody who speaks the
truth about Islam and
jihab and that's what we see
happening and remember also after the
Benghazi Massacre which was a Jihad
Massacre the Obama Administration
immediately blamed a YouTube video of
Muhammad's life that nobody had ever
seen and Muslims duly started riding and
killing in other countries about this
Muhammad video but it's now come out
that nobody in Libya was upset about
this Muhammad video nobody had heard of
it and they were writing for some other
reason why would the Obama
Administration immediately invoke this
video and everybody did Hillary Clinton
Susan mice J Carney they all said oh
it's this video it's this video it's
this video well think about the
implications of that my friends think
about that for a
minute what he was saying was our free
speech is at fault
if we would just shut up about
Muhammad then these things wouldn't
happen and so that's the last thing I'm
going to do I'm going to keep talking
about Muhammad until I'm
dead which may be CH
since fact is uh the picture of the
prophet of Islam that you get from the
Muslim texts is of a uh violent
individual who had his enemies
assassinated and who taught his uh his
followers to make war against people uh
gratuitously because they had different
beliefs and to essentially enslave them
and take their money and destroy their
communities he as the excellent example
of conduct and the Supreme guide that
Muslims must emulate also of course
consummated a marriage with a 9-year-old
girl when he was 54 and so we see child
marriage rather common
in places like Iran and
Afghanistan this this uh man is no kind
of
example and he is the cause of numerous
human rights violations and Untold human
suffering and if we're not able to talk
about that that suffering is going to
continue so
who is the only person who is in jail
right now for the Benghazi Jihad
Massacre the filmmaker who made that
Muhammad
video he
was right after the Benghazi attacks
arrested on a parole violation now I
don't know this man I've been accused of
being involved in making this film this
is all part of the defamation that is
regularly uh given to those who speak
out about Islam and Jihad actually I
don't know this guy I've never met him
and I had nothing to do with this video
and I actually haven't even seen it to
this day so I don't know what's in it I
don't care because I will like voler
said I may not agree with what you say
but I will defend to the death your
right to say it so
anyway apparently he's a shady character
and he has an arrest record and he was
out on parole or probation and one of
the the uh conditions of the probation
was that he not go on the
internet and so they got in on that
because they figure you must have
uploaded this video to YouTube which
means you went on the internet back in
jail now I ask you do you think that
there are any violators of parole or
probation out on the streets
today do you think that any of them are
guilty of more serious crimes than going
on the
internet do you think that anybody in
the US government is worried about
rounding them up and clapping them in
prison no of course not that
man and I don't even know his real name
he went by several names but whoever he
is he's a political prisoner in the
United States right
now and he is a hostage to the Obama
administration's war against the freedom
of speech and a betting of the Muslim
the organization of Islamic cooperation
and the Muslim advocacy groups in the
United States war on free speech and
attempt to silence us about the Jihad
threat not only that but the father of
one of the men who was killed in
Benghazi says that Hillary Clinton said
to him at a white house meeting of the
families of the victims we're going to
have that filmmaker arrested and
jailed and she
did and
so in the United States
stes at least up to now critics of jihad
and Islamic supremacism and those who
dare to speak publicly about how it is
in contradiction to constitutional
freedoms and has to be resisted if we're
going to survive as a free people so far
we are not being actively targeted for
assassination the assassination is of a
different kind it's character
assassination and the same thing that
happened to the filmmaker is the same
thing that is going to happen to all the
rest of us and the same thing that is
going to happen to all of us in this
room if this continues as it is Contin
as it is going now there are already
hate crimes laws on the books in the
United States you know if I uh if if if
I come to you and pull a gun and take
your money then that's a crime but if I
come to you and pull a gun and take your
money and call you a nasty name that's a
hate
crime now it's exactly the same crime
but if I call you a nasty name then the
penalties are
worse especially if it's racially
tinged so that's a hate speech law
already we already have hate speech laws
in the United
States now so far the implications of
that have not been drawn out but they
will
be and they will be drawn out like this
that people who speak who dare to quote
the Quran who dare to quote the Islamic
authorities who dare to quote the Muslim
brotherhood's agenda in the United
States who dare to speak honestly about
what Muhammad was and what he said and
did according to the Islamic Traditions
they will be charged with hate we're
already being charged with hate all the
time in the mainstream media but the
apparatus is already being put into
place to make this into statute into law
and what will
happen if we are all gone from the scene
and silence if we're all imprison like
the poor filmmaker or if we are all uh
fined until we can't do anything else
and you know and I'm tending bar
somewhere or something what's going to
happen the same thing that happened in
Boston only on a much larger scale
you're going to see attacks like that
every other week
because it will be that much worse than
it is now right now we're still able to
have this meeting right now this is
being filmed and it's going to go up on
YouTube right now I can still write
books Geller still writes books we have
the website at I have jod watch and
she's got at the shrugs and there are
other websites and Publications and
other people who are fighting for
freedom and are out there speaking about
these issues truly and honestly
right now they are but if we're all
gone then we're going to see a situation
that is like what we saw in Boston 10
times squar we're going to
see not only the FBI not knowing what to
look for and not knowing how to
understand what they see when they do
see it but we're going to see nobody out
there who is equipped to deal with this
or to explain it or to help help people
understand
it and then what's left then it's just a
matter of the dotting the eyes and
crossing the tees and making us into an
Islamic
State there'll be nobody to resist
nobody will be able to speak out like
Pastor Neer yes precisely like Pastor NE
mler there was a young man in uh the
Fort Dicks area you remember the Fort
Dick six Fort Dicks was the site of hot
plot a few years back but it was foiled
and that's why some of you might not
have heard about it because of course
the foil plots are very important but
they don't make news like Boston does
now the Fort Dicks plot was foiled a
group of Muslims was going to go into
Fort Dicks and kill as many American
soldiers as possible before getting
killed themselves so they would go and
get the virgins which is in chapter 9
ver 111 of the Quran Paradise is
guaranteed to Those Who Kill and are
killed for Allah Allah said it I didn't
anyway
the for dicks six they liked to watch
Jihad
videos they liked to watch like the
beheading of Daniel Pearl gruesome
bloody stuff like that they loved it
because that's how they
were they thought it was pleasing to aot
but they had them on VHS tapes so they
took them to a video store and they
asked the kid is teenager behind the
counter if he would convert them to
DVD and so he was working working to
convert them to DVD and he sees all this
horrible stuff going by and so he went
to the manager now I got to give this
kid credit I don't even know his name
but he foiled the plot and we all owe
him a debt of gratitude but he almost
didn't because when he went to the
manager he said I saw these horrible
bloody things and I think these guys are
up to no good should I call the police
or would that be
racist
now we laugh and it's funny but think
about it for a minute why did he even
even think why did he even hesitate why
did it even occur to him that it might
be racist to uncover this plot and to go
to the police because of the number
they've already done on us in regard to
any truthful speech about this matter if
you talk about it you're racist I bet
all of you in here have friends or
relatives who've called you racist or
bigoted because you have told the truth
about the Jihad
threat and this shows the effectiveness
of this
campaign and
so the Second Amendment is under grave
threat the first amendment is under
grave Threat all it takes is five
justices you know to a test case and
five justices to say uh yes hate speech
is not free speech and enjoys no
protections under the First Amendment
and that could happen happen very easily
Sodor and Kagan the two Obama appointees
on the Supreme Court are already on
record saying there should be
restrictions on on the freedom of
speech and so in conclusion I have to
emphasize to you that this all is
disturbing I understand but I am not
being
alarmist and I am not being hysterical
these things are happening now and
they're happening
quickly I don't think it's too late I uh
was born in South Carolina and the state
motto of South Carolina is Doom SPO
Sparrow while I breathe I hope
and so there is always hope as long as
there's another
breath but the situation is very dire
and it is very important for all of us
every one of us in this room to
understand that we have to fight this
battle wherever we are in whatever
situation and whoever we're with
whatever our talents are whatever our
time is whatever our resources are we
have to fight this nobody else is going
to do it for us the government is not
going to do it law enforcement is not
going to do
it we have already seen we're just
beginning to see the in incredible
consequences that are certain to come
from their denial and obfuscation of the
Islamic
Jihad it's only going to get worse so it
is up to us as free citizens to put
pressure to stand up and to make as loud
a noise about this as possible to put
pressure on the media to tell the truth
about this to put pressure on our
governing officials to make this an
issue I still believe that freedom can
Prevail And if every one of us begins to
act then it certainly will thank you
thank you very much you're you're very
kind uh I
had uh I had we have some time for some
questions right so uh yes sir uh just
kind of a general question with regard
to law enforcement andage um with regard
to Second Amendment we've been given the
line that the police actually favor gun
control when I know personally I seen
all kinds of surve that's not true by
any means in fact they support us on the
Jihadi side is that the same situation
where we're both into thinking that that
police want to ignore the fact they know
what the deal is and going on yes uh the
question is uh in regard to the Second
Amendment we're told that the police
favor gun control but the gentleman
knows personally many who obviously do
not and is it the same situation with
with the first amendment is that the
correct summation okay the yeah there's
a great struggle going on in all the
intelligence and uh law enforcement
agencies when I was speaking to them in
years past it was already going on then
the high ups were political appointees
who were politically correct and
compromised but the midlevel agents and
the mid-level officers mostly were on
board they knew the truth and they were
fighting a good fight now that's
changing because you can imagine the
extraordinary pressures that they're
being put on and when Brennan said we're
not only going to remove all these
materials but we're going to re-educate
everybody who was trained by them you
can see the kinds of pressures that
they're under nonetheless the great
Steve Emerson of the investigative
project who was on this issue long
before most of us he said just uh just
the other day
that uh he's still in contact sub Rosa
on the QT with a lot of people in
government and law enforcement who want
to get the truth and are working for the
truth and so this is one of the other
reasons why there's still hope uh it's
not just so easy as to say if we get a
new president who has some sense then
everything will be okay because I was
dismayed to tell you the truth at the
third debate between Obama and Romney
the foreign policy debate when Obama is
saying we've got to Aid the Syrian
rebels who were Al-Qaeda jihadis you
know and Romney says oh yes yes we yes
we do and everything was me too me too
me too instead of articulating a genuine
opposition we don't really have an
opposition in regard to the Jihad threat
right now the Republicans are completely
compromised you can't run as a major
Republican candidate without the
endorsement of Grover norquist of
Americans for tax reform it was an
extraordinary
influential power player in Washington
and Grover norquist is in like this with
the Muslim Brotherhood there are
cancelled checks that you can find
online from abdurahman Alam mudi to
NorQuest abdur Rahman Alam mudi was the
leading moderate Muslim in the United
States in the '90s he was the head of
the American Muslim Council and he was
another big Power broker in the
Washington establishment there pictures
of him with Clinton pictures of him with
GW Bush and he was tight with norquist
and he's now in prison for in
al-Qaeda there's video of him at the on
the mall in Washington in the year 2000
saying hear this Bill Clinton we are all
supporters of Hamas we are all
supporters of hisbah well those are
registered as terrorist organizations
listed as terrorist organizations by the
state
department and Grover norquist is taking
money from this guy and you can't get
anywhere in the Republican party without
Gro and so the Republican party has not
been in anywhere on this
issue unless there is a change in that
and that whole establishment is cleared
out and a new opposition arises this is
not going to change even
if a Conservative Republican is elected
in 2016 which is unlikely
anyway yes
sir I wonder if I could ask you to
expand a little bit on any advice you
might have for us on disrupting the
alliance between the secular left and
militant Islam that seems to me to be
the key and as someone who is very
involved in the fight against same-sex
marriage in Connecticut I'm struck by
the references to intimidation to
character assassination the brainwashing
of the young the lameness of the
Republican party all the things that we
fought the homosexual movement on very
similar to what you're describing of
course they're not trying to kill us the
way uh the Islams are but um I'm I'm
struck by the coincidences and it seems
to me that the key to Winning is
disrupting that Alliance how do we
explain to the secular left that Islam
is not their friend how do we explain to
the secular left that Islam is not their
friend it's very hard because Islam is
their
friend the thing is it seems like an
improbable Alliance but it's actually a
a a true marriage of
minds they are both authoritarian
they're both enemies of free speech
they're both supremacists the left has
solinsky who recommends that you not
debate with the opposition you just
ridicule the opposition demonize and
marginalize the opposition until the
opposition Falls away that's just what
the Islamic supremacists do they both
Envision I'm talking about the hard left
now but I'm not sure that there's so
much of a difference anymore but the the
the Communists whenever they were gained
power instituted A Reign of Terror in
service of establishing the Earthly
Utopia where the state would wither away
and everybody would be equal now that's
an authoritarian Vision Sharia also
envisions a perfect Society a perfect
society in which there is Justice and
peace prevailing in the land and anybody
who gets out of line has their head
chopped off or their hand chopped off or
whatever and so I think they're both
violent totalitarians at heart
and also the Muslims want the gay
marriage because they want to destroy
the idea that marriage is between one
man and one woman because once they have
marriage between one man and one woman
out of the way then they can have
polygamy and they were already uh
Ibrahim Hooper of the Council of
American Islamic relations admitted a
few years back that there are thousands
of Muslims in the United States who were
already in polygamous unions and he said
Islamic scholars disagree over whether
that's permissible in the United States
and I thought I read that and I thought
what who cares what Islamic scholars
agree or disagree on it's against the
law in the United States he didn't say a
word about that he didn't care of course
but uh I don't I don't think they're
going to make any Headway I me of course
you can embarrass them you can press the
contradictions and I do this often uh
just recently as a matter of fact um
Pamela Geller who I work with did a
series of ads on buses in San Francisco
and they were uh calling attention to
the reality of jihad Terror because the
Hamas link Council American Islamic
relations was running ads saying Jihad
is getting the kids to school and
blowing mil bubbles through your straw
and you know romping through the daisies
and and so it's a disinformation
campaign so uh she put up these ads that
uh have actual quotes from jihadis and
then the whole San Francisco city
council apparatus condemned our
ads which they've never bothered to do
for any other ads including viciously
anti-semitic anti-israel ads that ran on
buses before so she got an idea for a
new series of ads that showed Muslim
leaders say homosexual should be stoned
to death and so on because there was
this transgender who was saying these
ads were so
terrible and so we thought we pressed
the contradictions a bit and over the
years I have written many articles that
you can find linked to Jihad wise
of uh about Western
feminists defending the uh oppression of
Muslim
women what oh yeah uh many many Western
feminists saying that well you know this
is their culture and they're happy in it
and we see that uh they choose this many
times and so it's wonderful and not
saying anything about that life eating
is sanctioned in the Quran or that uh
polygamy is essentially the codification
of women combined with the easy divorce
not saying anything about the sex
slavery which is sanctioned in Islam a
lot of people don't know that but in
chapter 4:3 of the Quran it says that a
man can have up to four wives and that's
at one time you can just divorce them
and get new ones just like that to say t
you're divorced but you also can have
the captives your right hands possess
now the captives your right hands
possessed those are those are Infidel
women who have been captured in battle
now this is the Quran and you might say
well you know you're finding these
terrible things in the Quran that nobody
really pays attention to and you know
the bad things in the Bible too okay but
over the last couple of years there have
been three authorities one in Kuwait one
in Egypt and one in Saudi Arabia saying
yeah the Quran says Muslim men should
have sex slaves and the lady in Kuwait
it was a lady a a female legislator in
Kuwait saying that the the Muslim
jihadis they should capture Infidel
women in
Chia which is incidentally where the
sads are from and press them into
service for this in as sex slaves for
the Muslim men and so this is not a dead
letter these people are on television
saying this ought to be done in Muslim
countries
today and so in any case the
contradictions can't be shown up but
I've written quite a few articles about
feminists running interference for the
Muslim oppression of women and usually
they just say oh no no no I talk about
that all the time okay where and then
they clam up because they
don't uh yeah you know you were waiting